enfin ces accusations d'utilisation
d'armes chimiques s'ajoute aussi celle
des exactions commises contre des femmes
ou des jeunes filles des ukrainiennes
parfois très jeunes auraient été violées
par des soldats russes ces dernières
semaines les preuves et les témoignages
s'accumulent après le départ des troupes
du kremlin l'onu à d'ailleurs commencé à
enquêter sur ces crimes virginie hertz
bonjour on en parle ensemble l'onu qui
peut donc s'appuyer désormais sur des
témoignages très concret oui absolument
ça fait plusieurs semaines en fait que
les ong et les autorités ukrainiennes
que ce soit le président jusqu'à des
maires de villes libérées tire la
sonnette d'alarmé et des enquêteurs et
des journalistes ont commencé à
recueillir des témoignages de victimes
d'agressions sexuelles de viols
essentiellement des femmes parfois aussi
des hommes essentiellement des femmes
des témoignages aussi de témoins et
parfois même des aveux de soldats russes
il s'agit de dizaines de témoignages
recueillis dans plusieurs villes il
s'agit de viol en groupe ou pas qui
durent parfois des heures sur des femmes
de tous âges 14 en étant le plus jeune
qui a été qui a été signalée jusqu'à
présent certaines de ces femmes ont été
tuées après coup d'autres pas violée
devant leurs enfants d'autres pas
parfois ces femmes sont ciblés parce que
ce sont des épouses de soldats russes ou
parce que elle coopère avec la
résistance civile ukrainienne et sont
qualifiés par leurs agresseurs par les
soldats russes de je cite prostituées
nazis alors on part de dizaines de
témoignages pour le moment il pourrait y
en avoir beaucoup plus peut-être des
centaines ça va prendre du temps pour
qu'ils émergent toutes les démarches
pourquoi tout simplement parce que ce
sont des victimes qui sont traumatisés
qui sont meurtris dans leur intimité qui
sont incapables de va et verbaliser ce
qui leur est arrivé et l'urgence dans un
premier temps c'est tout simplement
d'aider à les soigner le viol c'est une
arme de guerre bien connus
particulièrement redoutable oui
absolument alors est ce que est ce que
dans le cas de l'ukraine il s'agit d'une
arme de guerre c'est beaucoup trop tôt
pour le dire parce que armes de guerre
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il ya
une véritable stratégie de porter le
viol comme une arme que des viols sont
planifiés qui s'inscrivent dans un cadre
plus global dans le but de démoraliser
l'adversaire parce que violer les femmes
en particulier c'est humilier une nation
c'est aussi illuminé l'honneur dans une
tradition un petit peu dans un code de
l'honneur un peu traditionnelle pour
l'heure on peut pas le mesurer parce
qu'on connaît pas l'ampleur de ces
agressions sexuelles et de ces viols
seule une enquête pourra le dire et la
justice internationale mais également la
justice ukrainienne où la justice
française allemande et espagnole ont
commencé à enquêter la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce que ces violons
étaient aussi encouragés par des
supérieurs hiérarchiques sa auxi
prudence pour le moment on peut pas le
dire mais ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
certainement des supérieurs ont laissé
faire au minimum ont laissé faire pour
rappeler que tout simplement le viol de
femmes jusqu'à très récemment et est
considéré comme un effet secondaire
d'une guerre que les femmes étaient
considérés comme un butin de guerre en
fait tout simplement est théoriquement
c'était interdit par certaines
conventions dès le 19e siècle mais
c'était le viol considéré comme une
fatalité et ça n'a pas été enquêtés
avant très récemment en fait c'est
depuis 2008 que l'onu a décrété le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a considéré
que le viol était une était un crime de
guerre 2008 donc c'est quand même
relativement récent et les tribunaux qui
se sont penchés sur la question en
premier ce sont les tribunaux pénaux
internationaux spéciaux pour le rwanda
et pour l'ex-yougoslavie c'était en 2013
et 2014 donc c'était il ya à peine dix
ans d'ores et déjà en tout cas les
autorités ukrainiennes ont dit qu'elles
voulaient que cette question des viols
et des agressions sexuelles soit traitée
à part peut-être par un tribunal à part
et voilà pour pour véritablement révélé
l'ampleur du phénomène merci beaucoup
virginie hertz pour le décryptage un sûr